dart a type safe general purpose
programming language designed for
building fast apps on multiple platforms
it was developed by google and first
appeared in 2011 and was intended to be
an alternative to javascript by shipping
its own virtual machine to run apps in
the browser but things got off to a
rocky start and it was never really
embraced by the web development
community however it bounced back in a
big way after being adopted by the
flutter framework and today it's one of
the most loved programming languages in
the industry it's unique for its ability
to compile to multiple targets like arm
and x64 machine code for mobile devices
javascript for web browsers and
self-contained executables for windows
mac os and linux it also has a just in
time or jit compiler which compiles your
source code to machine code on the fly
which can boost developer productivity
with features like hot reload and
flutter all dark code runs inside of an
isolate which is like a chunk of memory
running a single threaded event loop
this makes it possible to perform
asynchronous background work on a single
thread but you can also spawn multiple
isolates to run code in parallel the
language itself is type safe which means
that a variable's value always matches
its static type and that generally
results in fewer runtime errors for your
app in production however the type
system is flexible allowing you to use
dynamic types and runtime checks when
required it also provides null safety
which means that values can't be null
unless you explicitly allow them to be
which can further cut down runtime
exceptions syntactically it's often
described as combining elements of java
and javascript a dart program always
starts with a main function that has no
return value so it's annotated with the
void type inside of it we might declare
a variable with var and set it equal to
a string dart will automatically infer
this as a string type however we could
explicitly type it by replacing var
anything you can store in a variable is
an object and every object is an
instance of a class the only thing
that's not an object in dart is null
this opens the door to multiple
programming paradigms functions are also
first-class objects which means they can
be passed around for functional
programming or you can define classes
with mixin-based inheritance for
object-oriented patterns on top of that
it has a package manager called pub
providing thousands of open source
packages to help you get things done
this has been dart in 100 seconds hit
the like button and subscribe if you
want to see more short videos like this
and if you want to get really good at
dart i just released a brand new full
course for pro members it teaches the
fundamentals of dart from the ground up
to get you ready for flutter development
and my upcoming flutter 2 course which
will be out later this year thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one